l'ajout de postes
merci aux amis de venir nous amener la
route du causse
et c'est dingue parce que y'a que dans
cette émission où le public applaudit
autant une roue vraiment et ça je peux
vous dire du très désagréable pour la
jeune fille ce que vous venez de jouer
c'est vrai elle noémie merci doit hemida
travail vous avez vous êtes équipé d'un
micro oui merci
non mais ça va pas me suis sûr que vous
n'aviez pas microserv anonyme elle fait
quoi dans la vie
ces comédiennes comédienne merci d'être
avec nous alors vous viendra chaque fois
donc tourner la roue 1 voilà et où vous
amis ici parce que comme ça vous avez la
vue sur michel mr alors noémie on va
tourner la roue ensemble à chaque fois
parce que je vous ai d ici un voile à
raymond n'est pas que pour tourner la
roue pourrait dire aussi ce que vous
pensez de des chroniqueurs voilà vous
dites ce que vous voulez vous faites ce
que vous voulez ici je vous expliquais
le jeu et vous allez à jouer avec nous
chez vous vous allez vous allez jouer
avec nous alors c'est un nouveau jeu
donc le principe est simple
noémie va tourner la roue du poste il ya
plusieurs catégories
animateur/animatrice blonde émission
animée par nagui présentateur les
animateurs qui ont fait du one man show
animateurs dont le nom ou le prénom
commence par la lettre d tout ça on
tombe sur une sur une rubrique sur une
séquence et chacun votre tour vous
devrez me citer un nom correspondant
celui qui sèche est éliminé on passe à
une autre catégorie
il restera bien sûr un champion qui
devra désigner celui qui fera le gage et
en plus il aura des points pour le
contrôle de fin d'année attention
allez-y
noémie ses parts il faut répondre en
moins de deux secondes à chaque fois
mais bien moins du coup non non non je
vais vous je vous interdis attention
c'est parti allez-y
allez on démarre avec jeux de lettres
allant jeux de lettres alors les jeux de
lettres et ben c'est très simple il va
falloir de donner des noms avec des dvd
des jeux où il ya des hauts des jeux de
lettres alors jean-luc lemoine vous avez
démarré les chiffres et des lettres des
chiffres et des tweets hier à midi pire
un mythe c'est bon le compte est bon
le compte est bon c'est bon mot de passe
à dix des chiffres et dates vous oui eh
ben le compte est bon c'est pas bon
c'est une rubrique à l'aller n'ont pas
la même chose
il tombe bien le côté étonné que ça
passe mais je disais rien mais c'est
quand même un peu crétin encore s'il
avait tenté le mot le plus long jamais
ça et vous avez éteint une aura qui est
toujours là là pour voir où était niée
gilles verdez donc on pas avec une autre
catégorie maintenant voilà c'est parti
pour la seule première éliminée si
gilles verdez on reprendra attention on
va jouer maintenant avec les animateurs
de m6 allait zain le marchand oui
stéphane plaza
oui domino qui sort laminée aux dominos
l'autre lamido d'armide au bout en bout
javier de moulins savez-vous la wii
sandrine corman wii accueille guy
bernard de la villardière
oui
terminez thierry moreau est éliminé
thierry moreau l'ine et oui on va
prendre à gombe
on reprendra donc à jean-michel mais oui
il faisait partie ont refait tourner la
roue attention on va jouer à régler on
va jouer avec la lettre m
alors là donc prennent ou non
d'animateurs qui commence par m michel
drucker michel drucker c'est bon un
prénom nom mais on y est non mais michel
drucker michel c'est un prénom prennent
le relais vite michel non non non sisi
soeur naïma persie n'est pas connu
patrick dumoux moi je vous promets pas
que les riches oui michel cymes oui
mérité oui michel mais on a perdu jean
michel maire y en avait plein les
animateurs commençant par l maïtena
biraben bien sûr maïtena biraben ya chez
joly ou jean-luc meesseman bakir yahmadi
il faut aller ou pas 13 10 attention
c'est le sucer dessus bascoul a déjà
fait je donne est donc access france 2
quelles sont les personnes les
animateurs qui ont refusé
l'access de france face à ses voisins
surnom repart donc c'est par vous il ya
de l'état la fille d'athena flavie
flament oui ça non patrick sébastien
c'est fait on l'a pas proposé une aura
pour cette année là mais non c'était pas
beau la vie
il y avait laurent ruquier la batterie
qui avait reçu allez on repart avec une
autre catégorie
on a perdu et nos attentions
on va jouer avec des animateurs de
france 2 animateurs de france 2 jean luc
lemoine et julie guillaume oui william
leymergie
oui yves calvi non si je trouvais aussi
suffisamment oui c'est perdu
la finale la finale va opposer isabelle
morini bosc à ma droite bravo
aja luke evans
alors je vais vous dire vous allez
devoir choisir quand vous aurez gagné un
ou deux une personne parce qu'on reçoit
yvan attal on va parler bien sûr de
cambriolages annonce de son film voilà
le dernier diamant voilà il
et vous allez devoir mettre un donc en
bas sur la tête jusqu'à la fin de
l'émission et commencer toutes vos
phrases pas à temps attention à tous you
se séparera pas d'accord ok donc vous
choisirez ou jean-luc où il a belle
morini-bosc ont fait tourner la roue
merci noémie ce sera la dernière
catégorie
attention attention à les animateurs qui
ont fait du one man show ou qu'il faut
du one man show on démarre par isabelle
morini-bosc cépages aurait dit jean
marie bigard parce qu'il est nominé truc
à la télé oui c'est vrai il a fait la
place donc il était fait à plus de
ranimer la classe et auprès trouver
quelque chose d'autre parce que ça c'est
entre les deux corées où julien combes
est we go eco et ses mains j'allais dire
qu'on est allé battre il va trouver dans
le dur arthur bonne réponse jean luc
lemoine
il avait dit oui c'est terminé
non
j'aurais dit cyril hanouna est une
ordure spectacle c'est vrai mais bon
et je vais vous dire quand il ya eu la
finale isabelle morini-bosc jean luc
lemoine
j'aurais pu mettre ma maison ma voiture
ma famille sur la victoire de jean luc
leroy j'ai déjà gagné mais c'était des
gens vous étiez pas la lui que moi
jeux modernes
tu as
saad
mais attention c'est jean-luc donc vous
allez devoir choisir une personne
je voudrais quelqu'un que c'est un
avantage oui quelques avantages
physiquement et qui m'a avoué que
c'était un fantasme d'autres rigolez pas
c'est nora
vous devrez les marais vous devrez
démarré tout vos phrases jusqu'à la fin
de l'émission pas ce c'est old d'accord
merci voilà ça va vous faire avaler
il a un débat ça vous apprendra tout ça
et ça vous a vu vous aimez le style est
là allez on va passer